- It's been seven long
years, since we've had a
white male President, but with so many
white guys running in 2016,
can you tell them apart?
(game show music)
- All right, who is this white guy?
- Don't know.
- [woman in blue] Don't know?
- [woman in black] But he
looks like he's crying.
- I am not familiar actually.
- [woman in blue] Okay.
- [woman holding
microphone] Pierre Clause.
- [woman in blue] Pierre Clause?
- [woman holding microphone] Yeah.
- [man] Lindsey Graham.
- [woman in blue] Yeah, Lindsey Graham.
Would you vote for him?
- [man] No.
- [woman in blue] Can
you name this white guy?
- That's the guy whose
name starts with an L.
- So, he's the Democrat dude ...
- Is it Leber or Lever or something?
- You call this guy Lever? This
is actually Bernie Sanders.
- Sanders.
- How white do you think he is?
- Even his hair is white,
he's hundred percent white.
- Bob Saget?
- It does look like Bob Saget.
- That is Rick Santorum.
- It is Rick Santorum, Republican correct?
- Yeah.
- [man] Yeah.
- I really don't pay a whole
lot of attention to ...
- [woman] You should check, check it out.
- Most of 'em.
- [woman] Google it Google it.
[man] I will. I shall.
- [woman in red] Mike Huckabee.
Jeb Bush, Rick Perry, Rand Paul.
- Yes!
- [woman in red] Rand Paul.
- [woman in blue] You're
obviously a white person expert.
Who is this white guy?
- [man] No idea.
- [man] Martin O'Malley and that is ...
- It's the other Democrat, right?
- Yeah.
- [man] Blanking on his name.
He's from Rhode Island, right?
- Right?
- [woman] Yeah.
Is this guy's name Jim Hurst, Buck Strong,
Chud Johnson or Lincoln Chafee?
- Lincoln Chafee.
- Do you have any hair advice for him?
- Yeah, middle part not a good
look for this upcoming race.
- How would you tell him to
style it, if you saw him?
- Anything else.
- Out of these two, who's whiter?
- He's definitely whiter.
- I would say this guy here.
- Guy to the right.
- That guy's whiter?
- Yeah, Santorum.
- He's like a walking white stereotype.
- Oh, I know that white guy very well!
- Are you a big fan?
- Donald Trump, and no, I'm not.
- Donald Trump.
- Not a very current
picture, is it? Donald Trump.
- This is actually Martin Sheen.
- Donald Trump, is that a joke?
- Donald Trump. Out of these
guys, which one's the whitest?
- The whitest?
- Yeah, the whitest. There you go.
Donald Trump, I'll see
you at the White House.
(techno music)